В Україні за останні п'ять років
кількість сонячних електростанцій
у приватних домогосподарствах
збільшилась більш ніж у 60 разів.
З кожним днем все більше українців встановлюють
сонячні панелі на дахах своїх будинків.
Але цю кількість можна збільшити в сотні разів,
якщо встановлювати сонячні жалюзі
в офісних будівлях та квартирах.
Мене звати Євген Ерік,
я — засновник компанії Solar Gaps.
Наша команда створила розумні жалюзі,
які генерують електрику.
Вони стежать за сонцем, як соняшники,
і змінюють кут відповідно до його положення
для того, щоб отримати максимум сонячної енергії.
[Зелена експедиція
Ukraїner спільно з Green Cubator]
[Київ,
Наддніпрянщина]
Мене завжди дуже цікавлять технологічні інновації.
Я закінчив факультет кібернетики,
і також більше десяти років я займався нерухомістю.
Я почав вивчати енергозбереження,
воно почалось з теплових насосів, рекуператорів,
і потім я дійшов до сонячних панелей.
Колись, їхавши трасою Київ-Одеса,
я зупинився, щоб спостерігати,
як соняшники слідкують за сонцем.
І мене це надихнуло на те, щоб зробити сонячні жалюзі,
які можуть слідкувати за сонцем
і мати зручне керування зі смартфону.
Кожне вікно виробляє близько 200 Вт
на годину, і цього досить для того,
щоб живити близько 60 лампочок LED по 3 Вт кожна,
ще й три ноутбуки, як-от Macbook від Apple.
І в такому випадку ви можете все світло,
комп'ютери в бізнес-центрах повністю
перевести на зелену енергію.
І якщо ви ще скоротите близько 30% на кондиціонуванні,
це вже дуже цікавий приклад того, як офіс може бути «зеленим».
Це, мабуть, перший дім, на якому були застосовані сонячні жалюзі.
Тобто ми встановили ще першу версію,
яка була ручної роботи, як-то кажуть.
Працювала дуже повільно, був інший додаток,
який керував через Bluetooth.
Зараз ми вже тричі проапгрейдили ці жалюзі.
Як це все зараз працює?
Ми маємо тут три вікна, площею по 2 квадратних метри.
І вони віддають у мережу
близько 500 Вт/год.
Це еквівалентно 4-5 кВт/день.
[Фабрика «Solar Gaps»]
Зараз ми знаходимось на нашій фабриці в Бортничах,
де ми запустили дрібносерійне виробництво нашого продукту.
Це така B2C-версія, яку ми встановлюємо на житлових будинках,
балконах, лоджіях тощо.
Але зараз ми плануємо масштабуватись у більшу фабрику,
де ми будемо виробляти серійно B2B-продукт
для великих офісних будівель.
Тобто це жалюзі, які здатні генерувати стільки річної енергії,
скільки споживають усі комп'ютери
в офісних будівлях, бойлери тощо...
Тобто це рішення, яке може зі звичайних будівель зробити
генеруючі будівлі, які вже використовують менше на кондиціонуванні
і вже більше можуть енергії навіть продавати в сітку.
Ми намагаємось більшість компонентів виробляти в Україні.
Тут ми виробляємо всі електричні плати, схеми,
ми виробляємо сонячні ламелі-жалюзі.
Залишається тільки все це зібрати докупи,
запустити і поставити.
Після того, як ми зібрали нашу систему, підпаяли всі кабелі,
встановили всі ламелі, ми перевіряємо на нашому стенді.
За допомогою штучного сонця, ось таких звичайних ламп накалювання,
ми перевіряємо: для цього ми використовуємо наш додаток.
Перевертаємо нашу систему жалюзі до штучного сонця,
щоб вони повернулися повністю.
Далі ми перевіряємо, як вона працює з постійного струму.
За допомогою ось такого приладу
(це мікроінвертор)
постійний струм перетворюється на змінний.
Система у такий спосіб перевіряється,
і далі вона може бути затверджена
як готова до подальшого встановлення і відправки до клієнта.
Мені приємно представити Ігоря,
він — один з наших перших клієнтів.
Він такий «early adopter», як-то кажуть.
Пішли, я покажу найбільш інноваційний
пристрій у цій квартирі.
Мені дуже подобається функція,
що вони приєднані до «розумного дому».
Ти встановлюєш різні сценарії.
Наприклад, зранку, коли піднімаються штори, закриваються жалюзі —
разом з сонцем, то вони закриваються.
Це має функціонувати як один складний
пов'язаний механізм, сценарій,
коли ти просто керуєш своїм будинком,
своєю квартирою з телефона.
Це дуже зручно.
Дуже класно, що є функція трекінгу, що він слідкує за сонцем.
І коли повертається сонце,
то й самі жалюзі підлаштовуються під нього і змінюються.
А тут ще в нас є чудо-конвертор,
який якраз і «знімає» електроенергію із жалюзі
і прямо «зливає» це в мережу.
Можна користуватися прямо зараз:
заряджати телефон, вмикати світло
або телевізор і дивитися його.
Також я думаю придбати велику батарею,
щоб ще й накопичувати цю електроенергію
і коригувати перепади напруги.
Взагалі-то наші жалюзі дуже міцні
і термін їхньої роботи, ми вважаємо, — близько 20 років.
Вони зроблені з досить міцного алюмінію,
і сонячна панель може витримувати великі навантаження.
І вона не крихка, тобто не ламається,
як звичайні сонячні модулі.
Переважно комп'ютери, як-от Macbook,
використовують близько 30 Вт на годину.
Тобто один метр нашого вікна виробляє 100 Вт на годину,
тобто три ноутбуки можуть живитися за допомогою «Solar Gaps»,
і ще LED-освітлення — 30-60 лампочок.
Сонячних жалюзі більш, ніж достатньо
для того, щоб живити все світло в хаті.
І ще хочу показати: у нас є така переносна батарея,
яку можна заряджати від жалюзі «Solar Gaps».
Вона містить близько 1 кВт електроенергії.
І можна підключити чи п'ять комп'ютерів,
чи невеликий холодильник.
Тобто це рішення, яке може накопичувати енергію вдень,
і використовувати можна її вночі.
Ми працюємо над тим,
щоб кожен українець міг навіть зі своєї домівки генерувати
свою електроенергію і використовувати її.
Якщо вас хтось відключить,
то у вас буде своє джерело енергії.
Це дуже важливо і навіть більш важливіше, ніж інші прилади, —
мати енергію, яка може забезпечити вас мобільним зв'язком,
ви можете дивитися телевізор,
у вас навіть є холодильник,
який працює від сонячної енергії.
Це все може працювати завдяки жалюзі «Solar Gaps»
чи завдяки додатковим батареям.
На прикладі мого будинку я побачив,
що можна виробити більше енергії, ніж споживаєш.
Наступний крок — це побудувати фабрику,
яка була би повністю на сонячній енергії
і виробляла більше енергії в рік,
ніж використовувала б.
Ми порахували, що це цілком можливо.
Ми вже зробили певні кроки,
ми встановили сонячні панелі на дах будівлі.
І зараз там ми починаємо масштабувати наше виробництво.
Зробити такий майданчик для всіх інноваторів, які мають гарні ідеї,
щоб вони приєднувались до нас,
і ми б робили спільні речі для того,
щоб пришвидшити рух інновацій в Україні.
Бо коли я це починав три-чотири роки тому, це було дуже важко.
Ми хочемо зробити більш динамічний рух інновацій
у «зелену» енергію в Україні.
Енергію треба споживати там, де її використовують.
Якщо людина споживає енергію, яку вона сама генерує,
це найбільш сталий розвиток
для майбутнього електромережі.
Якщо мільйони абонентів електромережі
використовують електроенергію,
яку вони виробляють, ця мережа стає більш здоровою.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерки
Каріна Пілюгіна, Наталія Вишинська]
[Оператори
Михайло Шелест, Олег Сологуб]
[Інтерв'юерка
Оксана Кузема]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Субтитрувальниця
Юлія Леонтьєва]
[Коректорка
Леся Любченко]
[Зелена експедиція
Ukraїner спільно з Green Cubator]